your brothers and sisters are actors too
right
my brother and sister yeah Wow yeah they
were I mean my sister's an actress but
my brother my brother gave up when he
was like 20 he loves this oh my God he's
gonna listen to this high roll roll roll
this is the tiger roll a Rolo dog she
actually told me before we came she's
like my brother loves that show I know
because I didn't know who you were to
work on the show nobody does okay I dude
from back in the day I grew up like I
don't know watching you know MADtv
ensure I brought my rolos Ben texted me
it was like holy [ __ ] you got Bobby Lee
on your show I love his podcast I was
like Josh
[Music]
is Rollo straight yes I like his name
rollo what does he do he wasn't a nice a
photographer Oh does he live he lives in
Spain in Madrid oh I want to meet Rollo
he's good he do would he do it a photos
for Tiger belly he would love to done no
let's to get Rolo is gonna be our next
foot for the photoshoot
he lives in Spain you fly to Spain there
we will go [ __ ] go to Spain come to
Europe you know she refuses see actually
I'm never allowed to step foot in Spain
according to Bobby why because she's
[ __ ] so many guys there soccer players
at one point [ __ ] my girl I just got
asked [ __ ] by one soccer player and
you have to imagine look at look at my
body be real look it might be real beef
isn't it right now no I mean just look
at through the clothes this is not a
specimen of sexuality it's a specimen of
something though it is very novel it's a
novel is not yeah novel part I'm not a
traditional like man man I'm kind of
yellow and doughy and kind of like
roly-poly a I supposed to like her she
was she dated like a [ __ ] what's that
rug not true
I've always liked doughy boys that's
always been my thing in high school I
loved chubby boys but later in life
though you do were you were I met the
other dude you know they they make it to
the roster but that's not like I'm not
they're not specific to like my taste
briefly experimented with hot boys
briefly yeah man
and she's like dude those big penises
are terrible those veins
Oh hardbodies okay hard bodied man Swan
I want to ask for your advice because
you guys are actors
well no I'm being real I'm being real
because I I've auditioned before a lot
of time now and sometimes I'm okay I'm
good but sometimes I get so nervous that
I just I'm a desire